deeds, establishment of prayer,
and giving and they were
worshippers of us In this
verse, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala mentions as he does
throughout the Quran, prayer
and zakat together. And prayer
in zakah are often mentioned
together. Because prayer is the
greatest of individualized
worship of Allah. And is one of
the greatest or is the greatest
communitative type of worship
of Allah. So, prayer is
something between Allah and his
servant. Is something that a
person does of good to another
person out of worship of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. So, it
articulates to us two types of
worship. Some worship that is
only for the person who's doing
it. It only really benefits the
person who's doing it like
prayer and then there's other
worship that is worship of
Allah but others are by it like
and so these two types of
worship are found throughout
the Quran. This is why we often
find prayer in coupled. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says and to
lot we gave judgement and
knowledge. Judgment meaning
judgment in his in his
and his dispute with his
people. When he commanded his
people with good and they
rejected that good, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala gave, gave
him judgement, meaning that his
judgement, the judgement of
Allah was in his favor. He
says, and knowledge, this is
knowledge of revelation that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala made
him a prophet and a messenger.
Ibrahim Alaihi Salam and Luot,
they were related. It's
mentioned that Lord was nephew
the paternal nephew of Ibrahim.
That's is Ibrahim's brother,
son, his nephew, from his
father's side And that Ibrahim
Alaihi Salam, when he delivered
his message to his people and
he left Babylon and Iraq at
that time. Was the only other
person other than his wife Sara
who believed in him. And so
they left Babylon and made
Hijalah to Hashem. It's
mentioned that Ibrahim Alaihi
Salam went to Palestine. Went
to the border of Palestine and
Jordan.
regarded in the scriptures of
the people of the book as the
cities of Sodom and Gomorrah
and it's mentioned that the
destruction of the people of
Sodom and Gomorrah is where we
today have the Dead Sea. It's
mentioned that the Dead Sea is
their remnants. Is this true?
The majority of the scholars to
my knowledge view this as being
thee. The correct opinion.
Geographically that's where the
Dead Sea is is where was. And
the Dead Sea is the remnants of
the destruction of the people
of Lut. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says and we saved him
from the city that was
committing wicked deeds. the
sexual perversion that was
rampant in the people of Luut
is not the only thing that they
would do that was evil.
Obviously, that is of the most
pertinent and of the most
heinous. However, they were
also thieves and liars,
oppressors, and they were also
idol worshipers, idolaters.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
indeed, they were a people of
evil, defiantly disobedient.
People of Lord Alaihi Salam.
They were destroyed by Allah.
Why? Because they were people
of evil. They were not people
who did evil. They were people
of evil. They did it so much
that it became part of them and
they of it. He says subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
disobedient. He goes on to
state and we admitted him into
our mercy. Lord Alaihi Salam.
Why? Allah says, indeed he was
of the righteous Meaning,
throughout his life, the
majority of his life, the time
before the destruction of his
people, he was a good and
righteous man and Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala saved him
as a result of that
righteousness. A loving goes on
to mention Noor. He says, and
Noah, he called to Allah
before, meaning before the time
of before the time of Ibrahim,
and before the time of Ishaq
and Yakub, there was there was
no he was sent to his people.
And he commanded his people
with that which all the other
prophets and messengers
commanded. And he down to Allah
to save him from his people and
to destroy that wicked people
that were at at that time.
Allah said and so we responded
to him and saved him and his
family from the great
affliction. Family here is a
term that is more general than
those who share kinship with a
person. It is a family in the
Quran is not an reference only
to a person's relatives but it
is also a reference to a
person's followers or a
person's people whom they are a
part of. Obviously, family and
its original sense, it means
those who, those whom a person
is related to by blood or by
marriage. However, or or by
suckling. However, in
the Quran it is often as
well used to mean something
more broad, meaning not just
someone whom you are have
share
their familial bonds with but
also those who are believers
and share the same religion and
are followers of him. So, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
that he saved. Noor and his
family. Meaning, his family and
those who believed in him.
Meaning, from the flood, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said and we
aided him and saved him from
the people who denied our
signs. Signs meaning the
miracles and the evidences of
the prophethood of Noah. They
denied the signs of Allah.
Indeed they were a people of
evil so we drowned them all
together. Now what were what
were these signs of Noah Alaihi
Salam? Each prophet and
messenger has miracles, signs
to prove the validity of his
mess and of his prophethood.
Some of these miracles are
mentioned to us the
miracles of the miracles
of Asa, the miracles of
Musa, the miracle of Salah
and so forth and some of them
are not mentioned to us, but we
do know that every prophet and
messenger has miracles. One of
the miracles that the scholars
mention of
was the length of time that he
lived. He was given an
inordinate amount of time to
live and that is that just
amongst his people, he remained
950 years as Allah mentioned in
and that is just the time that
he spent amongst his people
other than what was after post
flood.
He was